the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to day four
of the 2022 fall chess classic we've had
a lot of fun here and it looks like
maybe things are going to continue to
heat up as we've kind of reached that
middle portion of the tournament there's
still a lot to be decided and we have a
lot of exciting action to go over my
name is Jonathan schruntz and I'm very
happy to be joined here with Grandmaster
Miro oh wow
how are you how are you feeling about it
just kind of coming into it we've
reached kind of that middle section is
this kind of where we expect to see why
do players really react to determine are
they still kind of waiting and seeing
what's going to happen or are people
going to start making moves yeah well
that that's usually the deciding part
like like you've started well but if you
slow down some people over past year
right but then yeah well usually usually
like the one who starts well just goes
on and goes on and that's a very it's
got a middle game over tournament right
we've known nine rounds you're probably
divided like opening middle command game
and me as the you know as the good old
Grandmaster I want to say and games are
important but if between six out of six
then you don't care absolutely and let's
actually get to know how players are
doing today uh we have two sections and
let's start off with these standings in
group a we do have a soul leader his
name is vidit Gujarati who is sitting on
two and a half points and right behind
him with two points we have ilionic and
Von Nguyen and right under that with one
and a half we have Yu Yang Yi Hans
Neiman Gregory
below that arimokobia Nicholas theodoro
and Surya Ganguly now uh Miro could you
please let us know what's been going on
in the B group oh yeah so I just paid
attention in a group you we had a lot a
lot of draws into love absolutely yeah
so round three result is the first thing
I see not a single drawing a big group
yeah I'll start from the kind of upside
down so Armani can learn still yet to
score his first half a point a couple of
players on half a point Christian
carrilla still can find his top form uh
well and it goes on and on and then two
and a half enough for a lead in the a
group but here it only makes you tight
for the second not even a clear second
so tight for the second we have two U.S
representatives Christopher you and Alex
Lindemann and ranak sadwani not only has
three out of three but he decided in an
interview I'm looking for the next six
games and it's exactly right
specifically mentioned want to win six
games but he implied this absolutely and
he said even too that you know he's like
I've won I've played two good games he's
won three yeah he's like I've played two
good games in a row so
you'll see what happens with ronik
sedwani as we proceed into that but
first let's get to know our tournament
this is the format for today's event so
this is two 10 player round Robins we
got the a group in the B group this is a
90-minute tournament for the first 40
minutes uh for the first 40 moves after
that you get 30 minutes for the rest of
the game in all three rounds you'll be
receiving that 30 second increments so
uh that's what we got going on now Miro
could you please let us know about the
schedule and pay attention here chat pay
attention this is going to be an
important day to listen to the schedule
uh well tomorrow's going to be important
day absolutely let us know eight rounds
starts 1pm as you can see on your screen
except for the last one which starts two
hours earlier because in case of a
playoff if two players are tied for the
first I believe that's the only case
where playoff happens so two or more
players died for the first uh then the
playoff happens the same day 10th of
November 5 PM
white is an important day we do adjust
to what's it called yeah Daylight Saving
light savings it's gonna feel like that
the round is starting an hour later
it'll be the same time uh but it'll be
Central Standard Time so it's going to
feel like it's an hour later than you're
currently watching it right now so pay
attention I know we are here on Twitch
we're here on YouTube we're paying
attention and you got to pay attention
Okay such sweet Thunder I see what
you're saying but you got to pay
attention to the time control difference
uh to the daylight savings because it's
going to be happening and this is also a
great time to let you know that if you
do want to get involved and you want to
follow us on social media please make
sure to use the hashtag fall chess
classic and watch all of the games live
on uschess champs.com now if you do
support our stream if you're watching on
Twitch and you give bits uh or any
donations anything like that all of that
money is going to an excellent cause
because you are helping us every 75
dollars that we receive will go to get
kids that otherwise might not be able to
have chess programming a full semester
of Chess programming in their schools so
it's something like 10 weeks with with a
grand master teaching some very high
level chess to kids so thank you so much
to anybody that's been gifting in any
meaningful way now with all of that in
mind let's go ahead and take a look at
the pairings for round group a today we
will be seeing Gregory o'parin going up
against nijan abisov Serie A Ganguly is
going up against Nicholas theodoro vidit
Gujarati is going up against Yu Yang Yi
we got two of the highest rated players
going up against each other we also have
ilionic going up against Aaron Jacobian
and of course Hans Neiman going up
against Von Nguyen what are you looking
forward to to seeing in this game yeah
all right well Hans you know we expect
him to score right I mean that's
basically that's why this tournament
happens everyone eyes on hands and then
how he plays so far three quiet drawers
one win by the way one a nice game
yesterday so well let's see so Hans was
the white pieces it was well kind of
Jumpy with the head I wanna yeah spoiler
it was a joker piano and I'm somewhat
disappointed yeah
yeah but uh it still could be something
interesting I mean it's still joking I'm
not sure they start off quiet but you
know sometimes absolutely so current
position at least is not symmetrical I
mean that that's already a big that's
already a big achievement we could
quickly run through this game just let's
go ahead and get from the start and just
see what yeah just to see what happened
uh so
that's what we call a joker piano right
and and I think I've mentioned that here
white actually has kind of few moves the
castle is considered somewhat clever
again some moves they say Fabi played it
against uh Carlson Carlson played it
himself against Wesley sauce how bad
could wrestling be Knight to F6 D3 D6 C3
but we end up in the same position sure
sure we end up in the same position
anyway H7 H6 and I think it's kind of
new to us because we've seen on couple
of occasions in the B tournament then
his coverage was playing this early
Bishop G5 uh development right so here
no Bishop g5s for you h7h6 flight Rook
to E1 and once again we are in familiar
territory uh three games of Magnus
Carlson I can see there are possibly
more so Magnus himself goes for this
line A7 incredibly logical so far Knight
to D2 and yeah and I think we were
talking so there are options of A6 or A5
yeah you wanna uh create the square for
this bishop on A7 so A5 is kind of a
modern take on this one uh Knight F1
white actually goes with something
pretty standard so the Knight headed
toward G3 uh rugby one though uh okay
hence no something apparently
uh Bishop E6 and once again I'll repeat
myself that this exchange with black
controlling the space on the queen side
is not considered to be any dangers
so black can save attempt would you say
that it's not dangerous or is this
actually like favorable for black
um
no no the point is like we spawn on A6
and A4 B4 uh black in order to play
Bishop E6 very often goes rookie 8 first
uh to capture with the piece right so it
doesn't want to double the pawns all
right a very important like he spent
more time on the queen side but this
allows him to kind of spare a temp on
rookiee Bishop to E6 B4 played by Hans
uh captures here Bishop B6 once again
one of those clever moves that I failed
to understand Knight D3 Queen D7 yeah
and there is more to that because Queen
D7 right Bishop takes and still takes
with the pawn all right okay that's yeah
that's
um something very good before and black
capture is only three and then you know
kind of second guessing perhaps why it
should have started with Knight C4
because yeah that that's basically what
you're looking for to play B4 19 24 B5
something like that right it's a B4
allows black to capture on A3 you go B5
and he's probably fine for now H3 Rook
A3 and yeah here we go and that's sort
of important enhances games right the
open file the open file
yeah he's opponent has both works on
there and Hans kind of avoids like we've
seen the yeah this queen always gets
attacked by Rooks and the queen gets
rookies a little bit Rook A3 yeah yeah
yeah
day four but this time yeah he uses this
movement well uh black wants to bring
the Knight to B5 which is a nice square
right stops the B Pawn protects the z7
pawn but this kind of breaks connection
between the Rooks in Hans uses this to I
know he didn't I actually thought he
already played Rook A1 no pardon me so
Knight A7 that's the current position
Wisconsin move so okay it's here to play
mirror I don't know how much you've like
paid attention I guess the Hans Neiman's
career or how much you've watched him
before maybe the sink-filled cup but
like is he just a regular boring
Grandmaster like he's just he's one of
these guys
what's going on that's the feeling but
like
give us something Hans we want to get
when he won against Magnus and and you
know all these drama stuff yeah and you
expect Hans whenever he plays to come up
with something absolutely and then yeah
I mean I'm not saying it's not brilliant
but it's sure it's way too solid in my
liking right
still still okay so we got this one and
I guess we'll see uh what happens here I
mean there still is a lot of life it is
good to see he's not trading stuff we do
still have a lot to pay attention to
here but we also have a completely new
uh other section so let's also go ahead
and take a look at who's playing this
time in the B section
all right in the B section we have
Christian carrilla today going up
against akshat Chandra Armin milkelyan
is going up against gangirli kantar
Brandon Jacobson is going up against
Alex Slenderman tigran hartunion is
going up against Dennis condrich and our
game of the day is going to be
Christopher you going up against our
sole leader ronak sadwani this is a very
important game for both of these players
and potentially if sodwani somehow with
the black pieces is able to capitalize
on this he might be looking at his
fourth win in a row Miro what can you
tell us about this game uh wow so the
current position I actually like it for
for Round Rock he's an exchange up and
white well kind of checking 10 moves ago
five moves ago white has sacrificed this
exchange it's not that he lost an
exchange he sacrificed it he he was
hoping for you know some sort of
compensation attack but it seems that
black managed to you know to neutralize
all the pressure now seemingly enjoys an
extra exchange okay still no
let's go yeah once again let's go from
the start so that's a knight F3 is a
very solid move for as far as I know and
then B4 right okay and that's uh well
the move exists it was well played on
the very top level by avronian there you
go Romney and the likes and before that
it was played on the very high level by
alikain himself so it's actually a very
very long a very very old line perfect
and the bit line would actually go like
F6 and then black tries to get E5 and
white goes C5 you know to play E3 and
try to use the diagonal okay nothing of
that nature has happened but I actually
played C5 accepting playing the banker
with the temple down which is which is
which is interesting right it's a banker
with a Tempo down then exam bit Yeah
Bishop to B2 Knight F6 G3 Bishop G2 well
everything fairly logical uh still some
games of same
a very high rated players the one that I
can see aronian matlakov went this way
and then the few uh sorry the new the
independent move Knight A5 so perhaps
something else was played in in those
games Queen A4 well some naughty little
tricks with B6 now Knight D7
A6 Knight A3 uh well it's a very
original opening like I want to say yeah
which would be great to see yep castles
E4 okay so black girls with E4 and when
when and if you take it he was 180 go
Knight B6 Target tackle the queen and
also take the C4 Pawn so white
it goes over there goes to C2 in White's
black to take with the pawn because okay
so here's where we see it yeah it's it's
a very interesting kind of
strange I want to say position where
uh it appear appears that black has the
initiative okay he played a couple of
active moves right but it's at the same
time it's black who's undeveloped right
the Queen's on ba the rook's only eight
so I see the following exchange
sacrifices a very logical follow-up from
White because you exchange the pieces or
rather well for a night yeah the active
guy the Knight on E5 right absolutely
and yet what happens he it doesn't take
on H7 I guess yeah he doesn't take on H7
which actually was quite attractive I
believe
might get trapped but at the same time
that trapping the bishop involves G6 and
that's kind of opened the diagonal so
that that a lot of wild things could
have happened yeah that's what our
tournament leader was or that's not what
Christopher you decided to do yeah so
anyway but Rook captures perhaps as well
like forces black to do something
because if you just care about the H7
Pawn a girl I don't know H6 or G6 then
white takes and and then like too much
of initiative right the e-file plays a
troll the bishop the open set black
actually comes up with an intermezza
which is D3 so he gives the pawn well
with the tempo but at least at least the
e-file is blocked right so the Rook is
nothing yeah
Bishop C3 Knight C6 and it is still very
attractive for white in my opinion but
then this is some somewhere here white
perhaps a lost thread a little bit the
night before he captured them before
when Knight F3
an id4 is still good still solid but now
without the dark Square Bishop at least
Black's King is safe for now
so that's why we've gotten Rook B7 Rook
D1 oh sorry Queen D1 and here we are
yeah here we are so if only this Knight
was able to say go to F4 and G6
potentially maybe that's what he has to
consider anyway
interesting so yeah definitely uh it
looks potentially pretty good for our
tournament leader trying to get that
fourth win uh it's looking particularly
good for black but there's still a lot
of game to go so we'll see what happens
in this one and with that why don't we
just go ahead and kind of look around
the horn Miro is there anything else
that kind of you got your eyes down yeah
well let's just try okay first of all we
have first result in the eight group and
guess what what's the population
yeah okay absolutely here you have it
uh yes yes it was that was a position at
some point I was checking what what
what's going on and there was a position
which looked worrisome for white okay
but perhaps nothing serious was
happening there
uh so I don't even know how to call it
it's probably if you think
Philly door defense with Scholars
reversed or okay
one of these white kind of trying to
play the setup normally blacks going for
it but have an extra tempo so Knight to
C3 Knight E7 Bishop G5 trying to provoke
F6 no such luck
okay
Knight to F5
Bishop A3 yeah Ilia
um someone should tell him that if say
if you're planning to fear it was very
fast there is that there is a fast way
yeah you just can get a bit of English
it's not as subtle though you'll see it
coming no but anyway yeah of course we
are making fun here but but yeah you can
imagine this should not be advantageous
for white and I don't think Ilia style
is necessarily to seek like a big
Advantage I think he wants a position
where you can like Play and play I think
that's just kind of his style you don't
need to know too much Theory just get
some position and then he he could
calculate pretty well as I think is I
think that's his demo Bishop H Street oh
yeah and something like that I've seen I
was I was honestly quite worried so
Knight to E5 Queen D1 okay and here
black could have considered some G5 G4
yeah
so and after C5 quite suggest in time so
F4 if Knight G4 yeah is kind of move
forward but it's not that scary I
believe because Queen D2 or queen of
tree rather Queen F3 Queen G2 Queens
knight from F1 does a very good job of
protecting both H2 and E3
right so black just returned back and
this is where as we were discussing like
you have an open file you have to print
Masters playing yeah
they'll just trade everything on the
open file and that's exactly what
happened the rookie one and black kind
of has a bit more space but apparently
not enough yeah
yeah and they've agreed to draw in a
like few moments
then you do need to make either if you
don't repeat you do need to make it to
move 40 in order to uh to offer a draw
and it looks like it was move 40. yeah
that was move 45 they agree it actually
overdid it that move 45. and that will
bring Ilia now to uh two and a half out
of four points he was coming in with two
points plus one uh temporarily tied with
our leader who is vinit uh we might want
to check out his game yeah
that that one is our two Heavy Hitters
the two top rated players in the a
section uh it and you young ye what's
going on here yeah here the game started
as uh the Petro the pets of defense was
Knight F6 right so D4 all right well not
the most popular but once again I mean
you check the names of the top players
who plays recently yeah she's Wesley so
with caruana and they promise he with
aronians Yeah Yeah so basically top 10
played this position with both cups what
are the chances we get like a scotch
Gambit here what are the chances
[Music]
fair enough Knight captures Bishop D3
yeah now you can see this Knight C6 is
suggested that the first time I've seen
Knight C6 movement oh yeah looks like
you get you know somebody confused you
know the mizora just blundered the piece
right
but you don't know this one I no I do it
was not played no it actually it is
considered nowadays like okay probably
the main line yeah yeah yeah but anyway
nothing's wrong with you I was hoping to
see our first like major Gambit of the
the tournament but no such luck yeah 95
Pawn takes Knight to C5 Bishop E2 well
that's known to be like very very solid
line for black
Bishop to G4 and that that's kind of a
little bit sad but uh what they do right
ideally you want to use this bishop to
win few times people killing F4 G4 F5
and but it just doesn't work yeah so if
you have to trade the lights go Bishop
apparently black is just absolutely fine
Knight 26 G6 castles a four okay
grabbing some space here we need three
and black goes G5 to stop F4
but yeah
yeah what's interesting I think like
when you learn chess and at some very
early stage you are taught that okay you
Castle opposite sides and then you're
sure
yeah and you don't care about anything
else and it's interesting to say yes
right they do push the pawns Like A and
G Port but everything still is through
the center like that's important to
control the center and so on so so
that's another kind of another dimension
not another installation of uh of this
attack against the king yeah so Queen to
F5
uh Queen D7 happened rookie 3 and here
we go it's an end game two grand
monsters I have bad feelings about this
one yeah yeah yeah
but uh you know this is the a group
that's what uh that's what we're signed
up for and you know what that's why we
also have a b group so we can see
exciting games is there anything going
on in the B group that we should have a
look at uh show me something good yeah
the big group yeah let's try uh maybe
something good is what we've looked at
already but yeah let's check those big
group games one by one and this is once
again christian christian querella 19
moves this time but he's okay true to
himself he's in a Time trouble I mean
these guys are both like at like 15
minutes and they're 19 moves yeah they
got it they haven't even made half of
their moves to get to the time but wait
a second but that's a huge Improvement
because a couple of days ago he had like
five minutes after 11 moves all right
yeah so there's a bright side yeah being
out of shape or rather not having enough
practice that usually has this effect
that you tend to double check yourself
not too sure absolutely believe yourself
what's akshat's excuse
uh this this I don't really know yeah
but with Christian I mean not only he
was not playing but he was also like
working on chess a lot right so there
was a commentary but also like trainings
absolutely so you well that's the worst
part of James because
yeah training training other people yeah
it's not good for your chest
well he's not good for your practical
chat so you learn to do like a lot of
openings you understand perhaps the
positions better but when you are back
to the board uh well training with
Grandmasters with good players usually
means what preparing the openings right
sure so you've prepared the openings and
then you developed this pattern of okay
I have a good position after 10 moves
next task so you're not interested to
play your good positions I mean that
that's the problem when you're a coach
do you think there's also because you're
doing it for somebody else it's not
something you're yeah technically
implementing I'm I'm really familiar
with this thing that it seems yeah I've
done such a lot of opening research I
can play in everything but you sure
can't play anything because you don't
remember as a single yeah I guess I
would have thought that it would be the
opposite in the sense that like okay I
do you know I've streamed for chess I've
played like YouTube videos yeah and that
is very helpful but I guess at the same
time I'm also doing things that like
directly benefit me and it's something
that you know would be like that
experience kind of like helps me like
taping taping yourself talking about
Chess that's helpful yeah I'm wondering
if it's more you're helping somebody
else specifically that it doesn't help
you as well yeah well I'm afraid the
thing is like when you are not an active
player on a constant basis like all the
time you tend to take this one like less
responsibilities yeah so yeah I finally
I've analyzed it should I remember it or
kind of memorize it not really I will
not play it sure yeah you know so you
have tons of opening your analysis on
your laptop and you don't remember a
thing
okay anyway anyway back to back to
reality so there was a French defense I
reckon not really it was the Sicilian in
fact so the structure looks like a
French defense so it was a sicilian and
I have difficulties naming this one I
mean Khan Polson
very similar something so F4 and then D5
E5 97 and I wonder if it's just kind of
a straight transposition into the French
it might be so yes castles H4 and that's
usually
it's not that white is planning to like
push both pawns and open the files
because nobody's going to give you that
much time so but H4 is very useful move
anyway because sometimes Rook will join
like this or to G3 as in our game I
believe it's a trade here 92 A5 yeah
logical once again a five before
developed that French Bishop which well
technically is a sicilian Bishop but
still bad on C8 Rook to G3 Bishop A6 F5
that's uh usually how white goes about
this position he takes Bishop captures
Queen captures and Knight to D4 all
right so now he finally has a threat uh
boy Christian E6 Pawn takes Rook to G7
yeah that's what we are planning all
right that's what we are planning let's
see let's see what Chandra has to say
this is one of the more interesting
games
I guess um just because we've sacked
upon there is this attack so far I mean
we've seen with maybe one exception in
most of these games like whoever's
attacking the defender seems to have the
advantage whatever like whoever's
defending seems to actually just defend
like a pawn up and they win but I don't
know this one looks dangerous The Rook
looks really strong there's gonna be all
sorts of tactics on the G7 Square uh I'm
actually really looking forward to
seeing how this one transpires
uh yep and with no time why don't you
just throw in that they gotta make all
these moves in just a couple minutes
each so we'll see what happens here yeah
looking forward to that probably will be
a very exciting game then uh the very
next one michaelian against uh Contour
uh not as thrilling because it's an end
game and that's yeah if you in case you
guys were wondering what the opening
what opening there was that's something
that is
sure blade yeah okay by Wesley saw him
on others played a lot I mean I believe
Wesley is like he simply solved this end
game
so he makes a draw against literally
everyone I believe he could draw a
machine in this one castles yeah Bishop
C4 Knight to E5 okay
ah yes point being if you capture it's a
check and takes on Ft okay nice okay
okay 95 check over here captures on F6
captures only four well perhaps white
has slightly better structure but
materials equal opposite colored Bishops
black has quite a lot of room to work
with let's say yeah I'm allowed to lose
a pawn trade the knights trade couple of
Rooks still the position would be draw
okay and so they continue playing and I
don't see white losing this one so good
news for Michael Leon that he's finally
gonna get something on the board
yeah
it's good to see everybody getting on
the board at least a little bit here and
so that's what we got going on there
then we have
uh Brendan Jacobson against Alexander
Linderman and Lindemann has won an
exchange oh wow okay
27 moves into the game uh Brandon is
down to two minutes I don't know what
happens with Brandon
said but he seems to be one of those
people who are big fans of time travels
all right let's see what happens all
right Queen's government accepted E36 C5
A6 while everything's solid and this is
the kind of the first Crossroad where
you have all those like various moves
like Bishop B3 uh some boring people me
included like dc5 just play Just opt for
an end game B3 is also a move of course
B3 B6 Bishop A3 though interesting is
something that you would probably not
expect like Bishop B2 looks much more
sure
um I don't know appealing D5 well it
happens to be that it is a theory played
by some big names like Mahmoud Yara
varonium for instance had this position
and they are following the yeah this
momentar ferronian game
disappeared so apparently we are played
something else but we still have like
liquid plays this line with black all
the time it turns out and Bishop C4 was
you can see the the time on the clock
too so Brandon has spent 30 minutes at
this point this is how he's starting to
get in trouble his opponent is up four
minutes from when he started so all
right
Linda renew everything nothing was a
surprise he had B5 castles and well it
does look pretty standard to be honest
for this kind of thing it also just kind
of looks like a variation where it would
be like white kind of doing the surprise
on black but somehow it feels like black
new all of the moves maybe better than
Brandon Jacobson or maybe he's just
taking a little bit of time who really
knows and yeah and the C4 is probably a
strong move
feels like a strong move if it works
tactically and knowing how the game
develops apparently it does yeah hp2
Bishop to B7 so white was not inclined
to take with the bishop on C4 because
some some pins right sure yeah that
could be very interesting Rook to B1
Bishop C5 and here Brandon decided to
capture on F6 caption C4
okay Queen E7 uh not sure what 27 is
about okay Queen B2 Bishop takes e
four and white couldn't come up with
anything better than basically
surrendering The Exchange so he captured
on B6 captured on A6 I wait a sec was he
forced though he could now that I see it
he could move the Rook to C1 and perhaps
be slightly worse because of the kind of
pair of Bishops and F2 being weak so it
might have been that he blundered after
Bishop A6 Rook B8 he possibly blunded
the fact that the Rooks hanging and also
Bishop F2 is that now
what am I saying like like I really
wanted to you know make a case that yeah
there was a was a blunder there's Queen
takes group too yeah Rook B to E1
so there is no Bishop of
Ayah but could it be that you don't have
a move with the Rook I don't know about
this point okay rookie one was played
Bishop A5 Lenderman takes only one ghost
Queen F6 Queen E4 Queen A6 and I'm
afraid Brandon is going down in in this
one yes he has one Pawn for an exchange
but you know it's a knight and not the
bishop right so say with light Square
Bishop somewhere on B5 so you anchor the
pawn and also there is quite a quite a
lot of positions when you go Bishop
Against The Rook on One Wing three
versus three or rather two versus two
and be a known Fortress with Knight not
so many so I think black's chances are
very is this now just like actually like
a relatively simple conversion is this
just winning for black or is this I
don't think so I would think so the
black just has to be like not even like
utmost precise but just don't do
anything stupid sure don't
trade the Queens trade a pair of Rooks
win the A4 pool and win three versus
three that should be okay if not trivial
not very hard
so we'll see if uh black here Lenderman
is able to convert this one
that's what we're waiting to see what
else do we got on the agenda yeah well
let's finish with the big group anyway
so we have one more game Dennis coverage
with black against the Grand harukunyan
and this I'm guessing looks like a
king's Indian let's find out all right
uh well it wasn't exactly the king's
Indian but it transposed it okay yes it
started like
E5 E4 and funny enough in those old
encyclopedias I'm actually not sure if
it's correct but he was named the
Ukrainian variation
when you put the bishop on E7
and so on
uh G6 Bishop B2 Bishop G7 leads to the
king's Indian with Knight B8 to D7 MILF
right okay Bishop E3 C7 C6 and white
traded on A5 which is usually not
considered to be anything dangerous
Queen D6 but Queen quite easily gets
evicted from here Bishop f8 Queen C7
looks very comfortable for black if you
ask me Knight C5 and eventually black is
trying to get to this default Square so
that's a difference right the open file
uh well white committed the pawns to C4
and E4 so there is no Pawn that will
potentially guard the force clear
while black steel has quite conveniently
his Pawn on C6 so D5 square is
controlled now a very interesting trade
I mean I mean well don't want to say
scandalous but like voluntarily taking
the Knight okay landing on the D4 Square
yeah like trading the Knight with the
dogs for Bishop and knowing that your D4
is kind of a weak spot but perhaps some
you know some concrete calculations so
Knight A4 Bishop doesn't even move okay
92 Bishop B6 Knight B3 and so he blocks
it right so white idea was yeah pushed
the bishop to say A7 and then I go C5
the bishop is not great okay black trade
skills here and guess Rook D4 that's
once again that's very standard idea for
the king's Indian
sometimes even sacrificing the pawn but
then the bishop gets to B8 and something
starts to happen on this on this
diagonal and the Knight on A4 will be
somewhat off-site interesting white
girls Bishop 3 25 D1 Rook d8 B4 traded
Rook D7 protected the Pawn King G7 okay
this is somewhat like slow-ish to my
taste but let's see Queen D3 I'll check
on H2 that that that's getting like
quite close that surprise
no no I'm surprised that white allowed
the check okay um saying that he's
totally safe you can check me again I go
to YouTube
uh easy though is there a good way to
prevent it
yeah he probably didn't want to play G3
anywhere because of because of actually
some yeah some H5 H4 business or if you
go H4 then part of G5 happens
anyway okay uh Bishop B5 traded H4 white
is not in rush to return with the King
so now this Knight goes to C7 and I'm
guessing not even E6 but B5 C3 so that's
an interesting route
not a happy animal
so yeah if any side's better it's black
perhaps
and yeah
he couldn't help himself
yeah black is better but not much so
finally mirror spot on analysis
wonderful so that's what's going on here
in our game uh Dennis Kendrick with a
small advantage against tigran hartunian
yeah and I'm back to the a section
because the Rob came that we did not
cover uh Ganguly against theodoro it's
already an end game opposite color
Bishops even even amount of Pawns but
white is still kinda where they're still
trying that that was a very original
opening here as much as it goes for
Sicilian alapin
Knight F3
original in a way that black played C4
line sure which well used to be topical
at some point but I think nowadays that
there are kind of more reliable ways to
play for black anime okay so castles
Bishop G4 Rook to E1 Queen to E2 E5
Knight A3 and yeah once again
I find it amazing that
you know we teach the beginners the the
players we won't be starting we teach
them try to take the control over the
center and right develop your pieces do
not go with the Knight of the edge of
the board and then you see two grand
monsters playing it the guy has the
bishop on C1 yeah you know it's not even
that obvious how that Bishop gets into
the game yeah Knight A3 is a strong move
and yeah and yeah people looking in your
eyes and asking Okay so
that means you teach me the way not to
become a grandma that's obviously The
Grandmaster plays
uh G6 uh well like I don't know if he
could probably probably he could defend
the C4 Pawn somehow but he decided to
sacrifice it because he has this capture
just he goes F5 and was helping to use
the unsafe position of the white king
Bishop goes to A4 ah that's amazing I
said yeah yeah I said like using the
position that unsafe position of the
king and then he trades the Queens
immediately yeah very logical crypto D3
Bishop C4 he was that
black doesn't take of course who needs
this Pawn anyway the four Bishop G7 yeah
well here I kind of do understand that
capturing perhaps I mean with some
checks on this e-file or Bishop F4 first
yeah perhaps Bishop F4 is very annoying
because now Rook is attacked after Rook
d8 there is Bishop E6
yeah so that's that's the reason he he
cannot take on D4 yeah so white does
somehow find a way to play D4 which is
you need to you've got to find a way
yeah a good solution I guess King G2 is
a very relaxed move okay Bishop B5
finally ah yeah Bishop B5 actually
allows him to capture because now Rook
F6
and G5 and trade and Rook E6 it's a
black hopeful to win the pawn back
Jack Rook C5 not so fast says Ganguly
here here here
F4 all right and after the sculpture
King F3
it's a white intense to capture both
pawns Rook C4 and this is where Ganguly
thinking Theodore is down to five
minutes only by the way it's move 32 so
not such a terrible time trouble but
still yeah
uh yeah that that what what's the plan
of the group beat up so Bishop B3 not
really social because I mean if you
leave the fourth rank then I believe
yeah the game just takes protects the
five Pawn this one's hanging but yeah
but after Bishop B3 if you
do like Rook B4 then there is a check
and I think this is also very serious
Jack King C7 and it's a lot of options
for white I mean the straightforward
take the Rook he takes your rook and
then don't know Push by five you can try
some intermezzos like this and God knows
what's going on The Bishop's hanging you
know the Rooks hanging
rookie seven there are checks from
various angles like Rook C1 there is E6
absolutely so I'm worried about Black's
position yeah I think as soon as that E
Pawn if it can never get that e-pawn
moving then you're gonna have something
good so uh yeah sure exactly how black
will ultimately stop it like it looks
kind of like the pawn is stopped like
right now when you just kind of first
see this position but I think it's you
kind of as we're going through the lines
a little bit it's like yeah somehow
either the king is coming up and taking
the F Pawn or you know well and actually
look Ganguly comes with a very very
interesting move I mean the one the one
that is hard to consider it's B3 but
it's apparently very clever okay because
now
remaining on B4 is not an option at all
because it's two checks and the bishop
is done Bishop very well so that means
yeah that means you have to leave
and in that case
King E4 is not yet an option but what he
could do is Bishop to D7 and then yeah
maybe just take this guy right and once
again attack the rook and more checks
and then E6 yeah the e-pawn is
definitely going to get rolling here at
some moment so this is looking very good
for suya Ganguly yeah absolutely so one
more game uh Oparin versus obasov uh
apparents up a pawn okay all right okay
upper pawn move 32 both once again down
to 10 minutes so here we had we had what
what's it called semi slav
E3 Knight B to D7 Bishop D3 the
so-called mironation hey this gets very
sharp very quick this one could be fine
yeah B5 and yeah well the sharpest one
is the one that was played in krumny can
end match right yeah
some C5 when it doesn't look like crazy
yeah yeah here it's kind of a more more
not even positional but but black tries
to control the risk so to speak so
Bishop B7 trade happens Bishop E7 A3 A5
E4
so white is slightly kind of has
slightly more space but black is
planning to equalize with C5 that's what
he does C5 Rook to D1 and C4
interestingly was playing so whatever he
takes C4 E4 is hanging right so Bishop
B1 and usually when I see something like
this I'm scared that that my opponent is
going to play B3 and do things never
comes alive but yeah but that's not the
case apparently
uh so what happened was Rook C8 then
white at least has
um has the time to trade on B force a
rook place from the initial Square Rook
a seven okay and then we are talking
into meters right so maybe not t7 it's
really interesting yeah like okay seven
is annoying right
my general feeling is in these kinds of
positions with black is like never give
that dark squared Bishop away he's such
a great defender of everything but here
we see black just kind of voluntarily
simplifying the position so we'll see
how this works okay so he captures G5
captures here and D5 said what starts to
play like in a very energetic manner
yeah it takes it takes a D6 apparently
it's a huge threat some Bishop F5 is
there even Bishop H7 at times Bishop F5
Rook C7 traded traded captured no no
Romantics a lot yeah I was thinking of
some Bishop page 795 yeah no they found
all the trades
but yeah but what spawn up and gets the
Knight on C4 killing a G2 not like all
day
what's the word solidifying moves like
G3
men of culture you know like B3 so that
the knight's not hanging yeah you want
to chill and optimize it before you
decide to do anything else huh and yeah
and here he all sudden goes D6 because
it's probably not that hard to calculate
that if you capture F2 it's D7 rugers
and queen to E4 threatening this right
threatening yes very good Rook D7 steel
attack and capture and yeah black is in
a huge trouble
okay and now well it actually did happen
Okay D7 here Knight E5 right okay all
this happened 95 Bishop B6 but they must
be still white must be winning
I'm sure yeah Knight C6 or to start with
five minutes exactly maybe starting with
screen D5 just wins on the sport because
yeah 96 is the thing F7 singing and
beautiful for white yeah very very nice
so parents on the way of winning his uh
yeah his first is it his yeah it'd be
his first win in this tournament he's
been he's been sitting on one and a half
points so this could potentially bring
him up to two and a half out of four
yeah speaking of first wins in the
tournament is Hans
let's go does he have any chance okay so
something has changed for sure sure yeah
that's that's white porn on E6 last year
it was black porn on these days yeah
what's going on
yes after 97 indeed Rook A1 okay Knight
B5 traded a pair of Rooks Queen to C2
Rook A3 Queen to C uh yeah
I was kind of trying to Hype up this
Quincy too yeah the move is a Tempo that
the fact he just repeats then goes back
to C1 uh black and black is kind of lost
a little bit I suspect because yeah like
moving The Rook to A3 and back to A4 is
not well doesn't look all that
productive if you ask me kick H2 I mean
he's not making any progress but I guess
he's saying what is White gonna do yeah
what you are doing yeah yeah exactly D4
and complicated yeah could it be that
black kind of went a little bit over
optimistic with capturing this this
spawn okay
I guess I guess this was wasn't any kind
of was not concerning right but he he
could possibly Miss D5 and then if you
take it you can check and the knight's
gone wow and the Knight is attacked and
when he goes to F6 that's what he'd done
yeah white couches and you actually got
that sneaky pond in there yeah you still
have to defend the the B5 Knight so
Queenie ate and now yeah now Hans was 10
minutes on the clock on move 33 so at
least to play his move 34 looking for
the way to kind of add something that
like the Knight on a five just just
bring any piece and it'd be winning
huh it looks like a really strong pun
yeah on D6 you can imagine upon you know
gets Behind Enemy Lines it might be
possible to just capture it doesn't feel
like that's going to be the case it
feels like it might actually be
disrupting all of the harm yeah it does
well E7 is what he plays all right okay
so E7 if King goes away he can actually
enter with the queen one of the ways
like just go Queen E6 sure uh and if you
play D5 I'm guessing like Queen c5's
fine but Queen C6 might be even better
because like applying pressure here the
pawn can't be taken because the knights
hanging uh well they capture the queen
and playing king of seven
uh yeah that that would be I'd be sad
but but maybe not really yeah C5 and E5
is once again it's problematically
defending five years you probably still
can do this but
I don't know the other line would be 95
simply and then another check and
because the material is still equal
right then there is no argument why it
does have a very strong kind of
initiative
at the very least so say King E8 King d8
and Bishop f8 started tackling these
guys
so yeah so where are they in the current
position I want to just stay here just a
second in this position a little bit
played yeah and
one win went with King H7 so that's the
that's the one so he decided D5 is too
risky
and queen E6 is yeah Queenie six is what
we what we are thinking yeah I mean
technically E7 is not no no no
for some other I don't know what the
other yeah you can play Knight H4 you
can well I don't know I don't know what
the other move is you can see the yeah
my dish was not bad
the Patia but Bishop
sorry Queen E6 is also kind of so maybe
having even having some like Bishop H6
ideas yeah looks really scary
all right can we actually uh well we're
obviously going to come right back to
this one this is we're getting excited
but let's take a quick peek at the
Ganguly game I've heard that we have a
little bit of excitement as well yeah
he's she's just winning yes I see one
side with the bishop look B3 proved to
be very clever so B3 Rook to C2 and it
wasn't even it wasn't even the line that
I've suggested it was just say my ba
check and if you go to C7 you lose the
bishop so you have to block trade King
takes F4 so far equal amount of Bishop
but why it's going to take F5 what's
going to play for this to collect boss
spawns just Rollins A6 King F5 B4 and
yeah corruptured and that's desperation
right I mean yeah you decided to
eliminate those two past pawns but too
many white pawns are still on the board
so you can't really trade them all and
therefore the white just one yeah this
is the last move of the game here so
Ganguly is uh he was the winner of
today's game against Nicholas Theodore
so congratulations to him uh and you
know can we just go right back to that
Huns game Let's I'm just I'm really
interested to see this is the most
action we've had uh in one of these
games
F5
so yeah and also it has to be said that
one win is uh down to five minutes
mostly five though so they probably make
it through the moves to go through the
time control but yeah still quite quite
dangerous for black
not even sure what you do because you
want some plan to maybe win that deep on
back I don't see how you do it at least
not so immediate so you want to take the
pawn therefore you I have to move the
night I have to kind of move or protect
the Knight right protect the night seems
Mission Impossible because C6 Queen
takes C6 and you still cannot take E7 so
that probably means by that point you're
that desperate you girl like Knight D4
or something but then even C4 can be
taken no so that's other question
foreign
looks looks bad looks fairly bad all
right so do we get this interview of
Hans Neiman today okay by the way was
played yeah if we wanted an interview we
need to have a winner so uh whoever
whoever chat is hoping to have an
interview with in this game maybe you're
a big fan of tie-dye Von nguin as well
uh if we do have a winner in this one
obviously we will do our best to get you
that interview but uh but yeah this is
uh this is looking very good for hunts
yep and he continued with Knight F5 so
now okay the bonus were played okay the
pawn is safe and sound you really can't
play this because Queen is six and I'm
afraid everything falls apart
so the night's hanging you know it's
hanging and yeah by the way G6 you might
straight up take on this because the
pawn is still kind of alive
always denied yeah I always denied on B5
which is again yeah so it does seem to
be so this game does have kind of our
full attention but I also want to take
just a minute to maybe check out the
Oparin game I believe maybe we have some
exciting action there okay so move 39
after 95 Bishop B6 Knight C6 is what
operating has played this was another
one of these past spawn situations uh
get past puns they seem to be very
important all right uh well I don't know
if he kind of wins on a spot here why 98
you can block with the bishop White's
much better of course in many many ways
he's so close he's one square away how
do you get there it could be like a
trivial trivial way of winning Knight C6
I'm threatening to win so we have to
block so Bishop has to block and then
just take it and black is black can't
prevent night
yeah so whatever black does it's Knight
C6 back and then you push the push the
beep on and then you take the bishop and
and you win so so it's a
funny setup that the Poland V7 Knight on
C6 and then the B Pawn which will be
moved forward and black can't do
anything absolutely absolutely very nice
for Gregory o'parin who's getting ready
to win this game
he might just find another solution I
believe that there should be there
should be quite a few
uh Ganguly mean Ganguly we've mentioned
he has already won
is there anything else while we're
taking a look around we did it with you
Yang Yi that's the one that probably
probably won't see
well there is some excitement though
still right F7 hanging e fives weak
some more simplification but but usually
you know Grand Masters I mean there are
quite a few hands Grand Masters Rook end
game
Eagle material so I would bet on it I
bet on the drawing this one yeah all
right and don't worry we are here we're
live we're on Twitch we're on YouTube we
see what the people want let's get back
to the Hans Neiman game yeah you know we
we hear you loud and clear so rookie
drug ba it's finally this was the idea
so defending the Knight yeah finally the
Knight is guarded but will it be in time
uh will it be in time and now
something like Queen 2 H4 is another
option because you might have Bishop H6
ideas meanwhile yeah we do have the
result confirmed the paring yes he did
not win that game fantastic
congratulations to uh Oparin
yeah uh I believe we might are you
starting to look at like some sacrifices
yeah Queen H4 is a very interesting move
and you're just you really are
threatening to take one of these two
points yeah yeah G7 or H6 right and
maybe black has to has to go back we
don't know yeah but then
yeah let's see let's see first what
hunks come up comes up with because I
feel like I don't know what the movie is
but if you feel like you got The
Grandmaster tingle going on I can sense
there is something yeah there is
something very strong
this is like Beth Harmon Vasily Borgo
with the pawn on E7 I don't know if we I
I don't recall the game yeah I watched
the watch the series but yeah the game
is I was trying to skip to be honest you
were skipping the games you're a chess
player but but the chess part that's
exactly why that's exactly why yeah yeah
yeah I think she's done an amazing job
for kind of acting has been better Karma
and but still you can tell if the person
plays chess or Not by the way like say
um
you couldn't believe the acting huh yeah
yeah
so that but but that's uh I imagine like
we when we are watching something that I
don't know some other sports and then
the professionals would be sure
absolutely and we believe we're done to
believe yeah
oh man
uh all right so back to the B tournament
maybe or no no I mean okay we have Hans
he's the move he has six minutes let's
just stay there
let's just stay there uh let me try to
read that I mean we can try to figure
out the absolute like best continuation
here for white because I mean there's
Queen E6 there's Queen H5 Queen H4
really has my attention but I'm just
trying to work out what actually happens
like if Knight G8 as you mentioned I'm
just I'm trying to find some sort of
knockout bloat to be perfectly honest
I'm looking for for the way for white to
introduce this work into the game and
then I mean it it'd be too fancy to work
normally but if this works then be
that'd be amazing because you're kind of
switching the attention or the side of I
don't know said Central uh
you know with the all the action happens
anyway uh to the king side and then
black has Rook on B8 Knight on B5 which
cannot possibly participate in defending
the king that that means white has
overwhelming event so if black is forced
to go Knight G8 after queen queen H4 and
if Rook C4 actually works for wide so
you suggesting maybe it must be with
something even better yeah but what do
you what do you even do like Queen G6
possibly yeah Queen G6 because now uh
the Knight and the Rook actually do stop
the pawn and quiz the queen is free
because Knight and B5 is no longer
hanging yeah maybe that's the one and
maybe
maybe then Queen H4 at all not so clever
okay
maybe greenish four is not so clever
now that I'm actually kind of figured
out that E8 is not happening
maybe what's not as windy as as we've
originally thought yeah there was still
a cool idea though like like leave The
Rook but
I have noticed we have Evan in the chat
he's suggesting if we do want to get our
Rook into the game what if we started
with like F4 with whites and I believe
this idea yeah open the e-file open the
file just opens something up yeah I mean
if this happens it's clearly beneficial
for white yeah yeah agreed yeah F4
doesn't look that bad at all the way to
close the position yeah well perhaps go
with this black should try to close
everything but then yeah but then we are
much more comfortable kind of playing
Queen E6 because we do get additional
squares like whenever Knights move that
Bishop D4 will hit yeah maybe white
shouldn't rush and try for a Checkmate
but play a position like this position
F4 Bravo that that's okay even simply
kind of guest hunts his move okay I
believe it's uh yeah yeah if we all work
together we can all all play like Hans
yeah F4
F4 e yeah
what does exactly that's it's a very
cool idea
so D5 could be could be a better try D5
attacking the queen and Eve Queen C2
then only now we play E4 and at least
White Queen is not on E6
okay huh we'll see we'll see oh sudden
this 19 B5 starts to make a lot of sense
right no longer hanging protecting C7
which is annoying for white
and yeah white still yet to demonstrate
how The Rook is joining
it's after B5 I wonder if was the D5
actually played was this the move or was
this analysis uh no E4 was played E4 E4
was just played okay so here's where we
are before here I was happy with Queen
E6 maybe there is a refutation of Queen
E6 uh I'm not clear 26 Queen G6 once
again and black has this nasty threat of
Knight G4 and you might okay
one nah it's not the way he just played
right yeah it cannot be you never know
sometimes it can't be right no it can't
be right
Bishop A7 allows communion to see seven
in the wait a second Bishop A7
do we really want to do this
now you're thinking crazy no that that's
too much even for Hans this is too much
now has to guess G4 okay all right yeah
so now this setup is kind of much more
solid right and then the idea is G5 if
needed maybe G5 yeah maybe G5
yeah G4 yeah like for now perhaps it's
just the way to consolidate everything
right so to make sure that like won't
have any Tempe say playing Queen D7 or
queen G6 the knights carefully protected
in advance after G6 I believe still
Queen E6 is exceptionally strong yeah it
looks very nice so G6 is not a Memphis
Yeah G6 Knight H6 as well and then when
you take it's G5 and it goes on and on
and if D5 would seem to be like most
problematic in a lot of these lines yeah
probably that's what he has to do and
then let's ask Hans
not yet but well Queen C5 is one of the
options so we control D4 we got D7 for a
second time just in case and maybe since
we figured out to now D5 Knight is kind
of uh of B5 Knight rather is an
important defensive piece of Black's
position and then maybe we do not mind
any longer trading this night by going
Bishop D4 and next move uh while the
Bishop is inclined to do a lot of damage
so it will have to be taken then Queen
takes and imagine this position was say
these guys are gone Queen is on D4 so
white kind of has the perfect setup for
the material that is left Rook on C1
will be targeting C7 Queen on D4 talking
G7 yeah I still believe it's interesting
I mean because just like a moment ago I
kind of saw this you know exciting it
looked like maybe Hans was pulling away
with it but we're starting to see all
these like defensive resources for blank
do you think at this moment do you think
it's the case that maybe black just has
sufficient resources there's no real
problems still in a lot of trouble I
still feel like white positions is much
better it's just that it seemed that
maybe a few moves left and now it will
still require some technique and more
pressure and so on but I still believe
White's position is much better let me
check much better
zeroons game now we know zero three but
yeah
by modern standards g03 is considered to
be much better this is plus 0.3 for Hans
all right so obviously we'll be keeping
our eye on this one all throughout but
uh what else is there anything else on
the agenda yeah so we have two games
currently progressed in the a group that
hunts his game
video which is okay approach it you
guessed it right it's probably a draw
right sure is there anything interesting
going on in the the B group let's check
the B group this is where we have all of
our decisions what's interesting in the
big group not a single result yet well
not a single they're trying to win yet
uh right looking at my kind of wrist
watch I see that everyone had to pass
the time trouble okay
yeah and that's the first for us I think
when not the single quick games some 20
Move games yeah you usually usually yeah
like not all the games survived sure
so today is an exceptional day
and what's the most kind of the most uh
the key matchup is you Christopher you
against
just to remind any new audience members
ronix said one he is sitting on three
out of three our only Contender with a
perfect score in either group yeah and
Christopher you started with a quiet
draw but then he won two in a row and
he's just half a point behind right yeah
so this is a huge one for the standing
so when we saw it we we actually thought
uh ronic was doing pretty well but that
was quite a long time ago yes see well
if something has changed it's probably
still uh the better for black right
because he yeah I think there have been
quite a lot of moves in this time
trouble 92 black eventually traded on B5
when B6 H5 though yeah H5 is a very
pleasant move to play because
very often you do have enough
compensation for an exchange when
positions feature opposite colored
Bishops interesting and yeah no but but
seriously that that's um
I was surprised that it's not a
universally acknowledged fact but yeah
yeah actually not everyone heard it this
is do we need to put this in the rule
book no but really not in the real world
but that's that's a very common very
common pattern that very often like I
say your pond has two Bishops you have
Bishop in the Knight and then you are
planning to sacrifice The Exchange then
do it for the bishop of your Bishop the
opposite colored Bishops left because
now look I mean with this bishop say
elsewhere uh on a light squares it would
be able to guard those lights Quests for
blacks now like H5
basic rule Untouchable and also if ever
say Knight gets okay via F4 to G6 that
that'd be that'd be quite dangerous
Bishop C3 Rook Sito and also yeah look
quite very conveniently has so they say
quote unquote weak pawns on the lights
glass so it can be guarded by the bishop
cannot be attacked by the bishop and
this this guy for now is relatively
useless the bishop on C3 okay block some
files and so on and by the way I'd
prefer if it was possible at all to go
like Rook D3 and keep the Rook on the
open file because now it's somewhat
somewhat blocked here Bishop back to E5
Rook C6 aha so that's what white wanted
yeah a very beautiful very nice I mean
beautiful outpost on C6 whenever black
captures of course White's planning to
take with the pawn
think
as as of now it looks like what has full
compensation it's already a pawn for an
exchange right it's a very nice outpost
on C6 safe King unsafe King if anything
like light squares no attack so far but
always has to watch out for light
squares sure not immediately obvious how
black would even make progress here yeah
like if you're thinking white might be
better in a practical sense because he's
not worse how is black supposed to win
this one yeah that's right it's not
clear to figure out here right it's not
clear like why say White Plains plays
kimchi 2 King G1 or for that matter yeah
plays King G2 and just shuffles around
and how do you actually make progress
with black because if you think of it
like yeah perhaps the real and it's also
not real but the potential weakness
isn't have to put it how do you get to
that exactly yeah so why it's very solid
all right and why do we resolve it here
yeah hopefully check this out and you
know what Chad has been wondering you
know we're always paying attention to
you guys we're here on on Twitch and
YouTube and they want to know what are
these guys playing for what is the prize
fund for this event well in the a group
they are competing for a total prize
fund of 22 thousand dollars it's six six
thousand dollars for the winner four
thousand per second three thousand four
third and you can see it goes down
everybody is walking away with at least
one thousand dollars but it's that six
thousand dollars prize at the top that
everybody is fighting for and in our B
group we have a prize fund of fourteen
thousand dollars it is four thousand for
the winner uh 2500 for second place two
thousand for third place and everyone
will walk away with at least five
hundred dollars now I have heard that
maybe we have seen a few more moves in
the Hans Neiman game so we can hurry
back and see if there's any exciting
action in that game oh let me yeah let
me go back to hans's game uh two Queens
on the board is what I can okay so the
bonds promoted yeah what okay so how did
this we missed too much we need to see
every single movie honestly confusing
because look for played Queen to G8 was
played
and yeah after G4 if you remember we've
kind of cheated a little bit and I
checked the evaluation and yeah
what I've seen Queen GA was the only
move the only thing that low so the
second best move which I'm very nice
fine which I don't remember which one
which it was but yeah the second best
move was already like plus 1.5 for white
all right it was a tough move but black
did and Hans went with E8 Queen
interesting which is somewhat confusing
if you ask me okay I can quickly see
that yeah Rook takes white takes the
Knight Knight takes white apparently
just takes the pawn try to discover the
tracks and so on but what happens and
that's exactly what was played
so if Queen takes his hands isn't like
on seconds Rook G1 and he's gonna play
G5 wow honestly this looks like he he
kind of went all in
yeah G5 is she's deflection meaningful
he got to keep a queen on C4
he really wanted to keep that Queen but
yeah perhaps but how serious is the
attack it's not I imagine him playing G5
is in this position would be really
serious but yeah
uh was yeah that's a good question was
Queen takes E4 pulse oh sorry could we
take C4 possible instead of okay uh wow
but white has everything is guarded
right so he could hey what a rook you
want a good score and the check and even
like King to G1 and no checks for now
the bishop is guarded by the Knight and
white so probably probably that's that's
why maybe this one probably that's why
you take the other Queen
okay so what I was saying here that yeah
if it's white to move and he plays G5
then I fully believe yeah white has a
very strong attack but now because the
question is can what does black play
exactly here I mean he can try D5
shutting down this diagonal at the very
least
he could yeah well could be yeah like go
D5
uh Queen moves and then you go say queen
D7 targeting the Knight so once again G5
for now is not possible because Knight's
hanging yeah so it feels like Black's
gonna get a few Tempe in his defensive
setup like he played the queen D7 and
then probably bring the Rook to say the
G8 or something yeah I guess I think
went terribly wrong for hands yeah and
d5's on the board d5's on the board and
that's move 40 so yeah so the players
will get 30 additional minutes they'll
slow down black is upon up if you if
you're not getting Jack mated you're a
pawner so we actually have the very
interesting discussion that you always
have in Jess is there somebody attacking
you or did you just win a pun uh yeah
well Hans is not impressed well actually
Queen C5 relatively quickly
on number 41. so this is where they
might go into a little bit of a think
because they've just received additional
time uh and I also want to take this
time to get our first interview of the
day we have uh Tracy Stewart our very
own Tracy Stewart who is going to be
bringing us the interviews today this is
her first one so uh let's see the
interview with Sergey Ganguly
and hello I'm Tracy Stewart with the St
Louis chess club and we're here with
Grand Master Celia Ganguly tingly and
he's just he's gonna be here to talk
about this game against Grandma so
Nicholas to Daryl and welcome to St
Louis hey thanks um
so yeah today's game was pretty
interesting I played something that I
have never played before in my life it
was a Sicilian Defense and uh
I played alapin I have never played this
move before I always played Knight F3 or
some games night safely but anyways I'm
I'm making a course on chessable so you
know on the salad so I had some pretty
decent walk
and uh we were following uh
a very decent mail line
uh all of this has been played before
and we got to the following position
which is one of the one of the
mainstream and I went Queen E2 here
as far as I remember Queen F6 is kind of
only way for black to play you know to
keep pressure on the F3 pawn and I was
pretty surprised when my opponent played
E5
I think he confused with some water
because uh after E5 I don't know what
the computer says here but after Knight
A3 I didn't see a good way how he can
defend this pawn and of course you can
play Queen F6 but then we transpose into
the queen F6 line
uh in the game he played G6
and I just did not see a single
compensation I mean I just take this Con
he has to take here
and he played F5
I believe here I had a much easier way
in uh in the game I played Bishop A4 but
if I would play D4 I think it is just
collapsing instantly
uh this is under attack and if he plays
this I have uh rookie 8 coming if he
plays something like Queen D5 which is
what I briefly saw but then again Bishop
S6 and Bishop D3 it's just completely
winning uh I was unsure
both D4 and Bishop F were both looked
winning to me but only once I played
Bishop A4 I realized okay I'm still
winning but you know he gets to exchange
the queens and then the game is kind of
uh it's going to go for a long time
so anyway we got this position then
later in the game okay if he takes here
for example then I play D4 and his Rook
is uh sort of getting tracked
I pick up this Rook so that's why he did
not take on F3 he played uh
look they say it's okay D4
um well if he can take here but then
again Bishop F4 and uh The Rook doesn't
have good Square
so even Bishop G7 and here I like my
move actually uh initially I was
I was not 100 convinced how I'm going to
make a progress but then I realized that
he doesn't have a move so just King G2
and this King G2 is a very useful move
like every time uh the Knight comes to
E5 my F3 bomb is protected
so I'm just improving my position and it
turns out this Rook does not have a good
square if it goes to f8 he has to watch
out for some such ideas if it goes to E8
I have Bishop F4 pin and finally if it
goes to d8 then I have the bishop to G5
again gaining a Tempo uh in other words
it means
he cannot move the Rook he would love to
move the king but then I take and then
Bishop F4 comes with some sort of pin
again
so uh after King Jean he played the move
H6 he's also waiting
and now I sort of insisted him uh to
take on D4 otherwise I'll just take on
C6
finally my Bishop comes with the tempo I
get the pawn
and he he was hoping for some opposite
color Bishop end game but the problem is
the Rooks are not getting exchanged so
after
prayed he goes rookie six
I have check he cannot go here because
of root be on check C must go to B8 and
Rook C5 and now I'm threatening Bishop
D7
uh I was almost sure that he would play
Rook d8 and we will get a position like
uh this which felt pretty much meaning
to me I'll either pick up the spawn of
make him play F4 in either way making
will eventually come to G4 or I'm making
Place 5 and pick up the G5 part
so anyway he played the move Rook C8
which at first sight it kind of looks
like a blunder because I can take take
and give a check he cannot go here
because of Bishop t7 so he has to go
King d8 I give a check again these two
squares are not possible because of
either way he's losing one of these
pieces so he has to come here Rook D7
King f8 but he's surviving here
and even after obesity this could even
be a draw
so
um I didn't take on uh C8 I played the
move Rook D5 with the idea of Bishop
these are pretty strong with Rook C2
and now a very uh simple move Bishop A4
he cannot take here because I give two
checks and I pick up the bishop
he went back
and this moment I was super tempted uh
to play Bishop diesel
because I realized this idea is broken
to E5 and I thought he might have missed
Bishop F5 and it's it's a very funny
move I mean he can take either of my
Rooks but I'm giving a check and it's
getting matted so he's obliged to play
Rook season and there is just no other
move
and I was calculating check here Rook C1
check he cannot take because of mate he
has to come here I give Rook B6 check
King F5
and
I don't know I mean I thought it should
be good initiative but it's also like
burning the bridges if it is not made
then I'm not getting anything so
um why to why to go for this combination
at all when I have a much simpler rule
F4 and protecting the pawn and
threatening Bishop D7 next
so uh
oh the game uh the game did not end here
um there is a delay okay so the game
continued with uh he took here
and I played the king F3 I'm trying to
take the pawn
Hit The Rook C4 attacking my Bishop
I played B3
uh basically arguing that if he goes
here then I have check check and taking
the bishop so he cannot do that
uh she played
yeah he played Rook C2 so that if I take
he will take here but now check
I'm exchanging one Rook
and my king is coming to F4
uh he tried to track the bishop I took
here
and B4 my Bishop is getting out he's
lost desperate drivers uh to take here
and give Rook F7 check and I was
thinking where to put my king uh I can
technically put it anywhere and after
this I have Rook C5 and Rook C2 but
while I was thinking he realized it
makes no sense to continue I mean I can
put the king anywhere and then there is
so yeah I think it's apart from missing
D4 it was pretty much a clean game and
it was I was a bit Lucky in the opening
where he uh he plundered at a very early
stage and then there was no fight okay
well thank you for joining us and taking
this time uh to and talk about your game
um look forward to seeing you tomorrow
and good luck tomorrow thanks a lot
that was Grandmaster Surya Ganguly
getting his first win of the tournaments
and with that that brings him to one and
a half out of four points overall a big
congratulations to our winner of that
game now uh Miro I can see you still got
your eyes on the Hans Neiman game if
there have been any updates or have they
kind of reached some sort of stopping
point uh well they've been a few more
moves after D5 Queen C5 Queen to E6
because the square one win decided to
put the queen on not to D7 but to E6 but
with the same kind of slowing down idea
so Target did night and if white ever
tries G5 for now the knights hanging so
Queen to E6 and a move like Rook G2 you
can probably guess that's something
something went wrong because yeah like
when you play e78 and sure basically
sacrificing your Pride and Glory day
seven porn yeah I'm wondering if you
actually like missed something he
thought he had something or if it was
yeah I just still haven't understood
this exact decision here when he just
gave the pawn away yeah I understand I
mean you're probably not happy trading
the Queens
but isn't there like some other moving
not yet yeah perhaps like he
hallucinated or thought he was he was
winning on a spot or something yeah and
again this was like right before this
was in the the height of time pressure
here yeah
yeah it could have been that johans
literally was like one second and you
just had to play something yeah if you
need to make two moves You can predict a
couple moves there very easily but it's
just still he's 78 is not the fastest
move to make sure right I mean you're
playing with white so apparently the
clock is at your left so move the queen
like Queen C2 yeah yeah and then you
have to move the pawn put the queen on
the bread anyway yeah
all right so currently it looks like
black just enjoys his extra Pawn oh okay
so does Hans now actually need to switch
then is he going into like yeah that's
that's important just kind of hang on
there now that's important
yeah and we have one more result which
is a draw for visiting you young okay
again last time we've seen it our two
highest rated competitors last time
we've seen it it was it was I know not
here that they actually played a lot of
a bunch of moves very much there's a lot
of moves that were played from this
position yeah remember something like
that and even even further yeah that's
one we've seen for the last time and it
turns out it's fairly fairly
simple so B6 King B7 and then black will
kind of push his a pawn but he's not
fasted out because white does exactly
the same exchanges Black's age pawn and
he has a passport of his own right they
played a lot of moves from here which is
yeah that's amazing just to bring the
game to a logical conclusion so
basically the argument is that each side
will have to give the Rook for the pawn
and yeah that's the way to end to finish
the game in a drone I mean yes that has
to be perhaps not a surprising result
the two highest rated uh competitors in
this Yu Yang Yi and vidit have both made
a draw uh is there anything else
that is uh still going on so a group
it's uh Hans Neiman only sure Hans
Neiman only show and the B group not a
single result still wow that's
scandalous uh that that's well great I
mean that gives us quite a lot that we
can still take a look at uh maybe we can
start here with this game with
Christopher you and tournament leader
ronak sadwani yeah so that was like
right before they've reached the time
control this move H5 which I was yes
make any progress here was kind of where
we were left this one well it doesn't
look like Black's Play It's rather white
tries to make progress Knight D3 Queen
E7 there was a funny suggestion in the
chat which is I believe very strong if
it works but it is very kind of really
time consuming yeah it's like to H4 and
then G6
uh well this didn't happen but instead
white girls Bishop C4 uh arguing that
yeah maybe the Queen's gonna go to
Queen's gonna go to D5 in some cases
yeah if any any side is better it's it's
white you know
yeah I think yeah but once again since
they've reached move 40 it's been 43
currently for black to play uh this can
last for quite a while interesting and I
just want to give a big shout out we
have a competitor from the US Women's
Championship Talia Cervantes in the chat
and she is wanting to know uh can you
press with black in the Jacobson game
versus Lenderman is there something
interesting going on let's see let's see
London
uh that's the one that I've declared
like being winning for uh for Lenderman
yes I don't know I never thought it was
like so easy is this look at this this
is kind of weird this is like a fortress
or yeah let's go back let's go back a
little bit because
somewhere here it did seem to be fairly
easy and I think what black has done
I don't know if he was like
uh would you have something different in
here yeah I mean I'm not sure if you
want to play each
five here because he ended up in an
awkward kind of awkward sport that he
can't really
uh can't really go on the offensive he
cannot has perhaps no time to double the
Rooks on the second rank because some
counter threats of say 96 and also each
Five Pawns so we always targeted what
ended up happening is yeah
he decided to put the Rook on F5 and
that's actually awkward right Rook C6
not sure what landomon's looking for
so I have to play G5 then at some point
yeah it could be still but he would be
much better off like like swapping a
pair of Rooks early on so now now it is
kind of problematic because you have to
guard H5 all the time right and then why
didn't know annoys you whenever King H6
played Rook C8 and
to my mind I think this is very hard to
win with black like is there what is the
plan how do you how do you even do it so
now perhaps you're actually looking at
kind of a good moment to play G5 okay
let's try let's I just played G5
straight up
uh point being like if say why trades
captures H5 I wanna play Rook A2 and I'm
not saying it's raining it's probably
just just not honestly you know Jonathan
I'm saying this is also like like before
no so that doesn't work at all never
mind never mind G5 is not
yeah it could be in fact that's a hard
thing to win but that that's very often
the case with this Knight against Rook
on One Wing because I remember
well I ended up winning but a completely
drawish position which started as like
completely winning for me because I
thought okay what could possibly go
wrong let's move some pawns let's do
this this and then ended up having two
pawns each and I cannot make progress
with them I mean in order to make
progress I have to trade like one pair
of Pawns and the other one is always
targeted I managed to trick my opponent
but it can be so tricky even when it's a
full exchange all right but but I think
this is a anyway this is kind of a move
in the right direction so he has to
activate both Rooks he has to try to pin
white down sort of with the attack on F2
Square I guess if you can somehow set up
that dream position like okay the Knight
will be on H3 defending but I like it
yeah
bosses and then yeah and the Knight on
the stream sure that's right
so now once again we are kind of we want
to organize G5 but how to do them sure I
mean sure I'll just give you this is the
dream here for black yeah yeah fair
enough fair enough it's hard
so do this and then it's easier said
than done trade trade the road because I
can see like trading the Rooks would
actually help right so yeah
but of course yeah of course like if I
end up with the Knight on A3 which is
quite passive at least I'm probably
smart enough not to change drugs and
then I have enough files to run away
yellow
okay so this one I mean this is going to
be a tough battle I'm thinking I don't
know even if like it's an optimal setup
does it mean that we won't have a single
result I mean a show almost like coming
to an end we should we probably have to
wait for a few more moves at least in
Hunt in this demons game so let's think
we will Riot if we don't uh stay with
the Hans game a little bit yeah yeah
let's quickly run through the beat two
games just to see where we stand so
that's yeah that's uh the one from the
leaders Christopher you against ranak
sadhwani then Christian Christian
carrilla all right uh well they do have
a crazy position over there so Christian
is upon up he has he has three connected
past pawns but they are not where you
want your passwords to be uh or maybe he
confused and planning to promote it that
way
now if I'm perfectly serious if I'm like
really serious I guess black has to have
enough corn to play with with the H Pawn
and E Pawn
so I'm I'm not even sure yeah like Rook
H4 black puts the Rook behind the First
Pawn and
yeah I don't think white risks much I
don't think white can lose but like
winning with white will be problematic
yeah definitely
okay so that's the one then Mika Leon
and Contour okay here
these guys are not planning to go any
easy on the commentator still
everything's hanging a lot of a lot of
stuff
yeah give me something like two pawns
Edge Rook age and preferably on One Wing
so that I can declare it a drone and no
I mean
every game everything's hanging okay
plug just played the 65. I just played
the 65 and what's the debate here like
if I just take blacks probably not very
unhappy right 960 yeah well still
slightly better structure for wine but
whenever black gets active some perhaps
no big thing can happen
B7 ever an idea I'm just thinking yeah
maybe like just take and go Bishop B7
it's a very ugly way to attack the
opponent maybe I don't don't even
threaten to take because of Jordan seven
but at least like to create some tension
and once again yeah and and then in the
end that like this gives Knight D6 if
you want to take take because after okay
seven you're you're losing a piece yeah
maybe it's just
just a draw then okay not draw but an
equal position right huh okay so I think
there's still probably a lot of life
here in this one yeah I'll expect to see
quite a lot of more moves
also there is this one against cartridge
move 45
a and the last time we've been to this
game it was in exchange on E5 I'm
guessing right so Bishop E5 exchange on
E5 H4 somewhere around here yeah so the
Knight went to
C3 as we were discussing
yeah but the thing was not on C3 it
stands there nicely
but what you would like this Knight to
do is actually to attack the queen to
unblock the d-pawn and in this regard
the knights 3 is not doing much
strangely right it's kind of hanging
around on C3 and usually it would be
much more efficient with more pieces on
the board because it disrupts it takes
away squares but for this specific
material where we have
I think white has just kind of enough
space for all the pieces right
and let's see how this unfolds going to
E5 Rook A7 so white even starts to be a
little bit
kind of ambitious certain Knight has to
leave kg2 Bishop A4 yeah who knows I
don't think White's playing for win here
but
it seems that the most dangerous
the
the it seems that the worst part is kind
of over and yeah
I guess we've just had words that we
have a result in the Hans Neiman game
Hans Neiman game seriously
uh I don't have it just yet 26 Rook G2
Knight D7 Queen B2 Queen F6 Hans
captured on F6 and my my understanding
here is that I guess both of these
players have agreed to a draw in this
position
does that sound correct to you you can't
believe it I don't know
um
trying to count them Pawns
and black has black has
five and white has four right
interesting okay
all right so Knight takes
what could possibly be the continuation
for ah yeah maybe some G5 and then he
gets the initiative and and if he really
like if he captured on F6 and black is
thinking
then perhaps it is kind of came along
with the draw foreign
not playing on here I don't even
understand
ah okay we've we've unfortunately
received some bad information from uh so
that's just the position that they have
they're just they're still playing right
so it's not a draw forget everything it
was all fake news apologies okay okay I
guess these guys are still playing so
ah
okay uh and then it then it explains why
he's thinking because in fact G7 takes
F6 might not be that appealing but
that's a viable alternative I would
guess right this G5 is no not any
not not that scary anymore Knight E7
looks like attacks the pawn in an
awkward way but black actually will move
forward so that's not an option I mean
for a second I thought like 97 how do
you defend the D5 Pawn but you you do
not defend D5 you just make it that your
D5 Pawn turns into the default pawn and
then e3d and then they just go up the
board
yep so there is that uh so the position
is a white captured one F6 and hans's
opponent continues to think
so right one game in the a section and
no results
five games going
okay all right I got a full promise the
game is a draw
now I don't believe anything anyone's
saying in my ear anymore but I have
heard that this is officially a draw
okay so this is officially a draw and so
what do we do then it's the end of kind
of but by the time it's supposed to be
like are we supposed to be rubbing up
the show yeah we do have the a group all
done perfect but the group
so we still have the entire B group yeah
yeah but you know what it is a 90 minute
show and they're throwing it up all
right they're kicking us out of here we
got the standings uh for group a which
is now uh we did see that that one game
that you see there is pending was a draw
which means that we now have it at three
and a half ilionic on Two and a Half
great girl of RNA two and a half uh Von
Nguyen now actually will be leaping up
in 2-3 meaning he is now uh died for uh
the lead as you can see there
um or maybe he's at two and a half yeah
he's already that would make a little
bit more yeah we still have a clear
leader in the a section it is vidit
Gujarati uh and now we can see it again
on Two and a Half we got ilione Gregory
o'parin and Von Nguyen at two points we
got Yu Yang Yi and Hans Neiman below
that we got ninja
Ganguly and Nicholas theodoro
in the B group
we also have a clear winner in the B
group even though again nothing has been
finalized there's still quite a lot
going on there but uh they're exactly
the same as when we came in we got runic
zadwani at the top of the leaderboard
playing Christopher you who's sitting on
two and a half so a lot of interesting
things will have some major updates when
we come back tomorrow reminder again
that tomorrow is uh daylight savings
time is ending here on our show so it's
going to feel like the show is starting
one hour later than it did today so make
sure you double check very carefully
about the start time of tomorrow's round
again make sure you follow us with the
hashtag fall chess classic you can watch
all of our games live on us chess Champs
we're here on Twitch we're on here on
YouTube thank you everybody for uh
hanging out with us having such a fun
game and Miro do you have any final
thoughts about what we've seen today yes
I do B Group B Group B group that is a
real Sportsmen yeah
come back tomorrow
amazing day
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited